this is an ask Alabama we are an unarmed  freighter we have the potential privacy  situation copy Alabama you should alert  your crew get your fire hoses ready the  chances are it's just fishermen they're  not here to fish  listen up we have been boarded by armed  pirates fools naked middlecoff nobody  hostages we will follow the procedures  to lockdown go get in the water and wait  forever  it will be alright  look at me look at me  the Navy is not going to let you win  they would rather sink this boat gonna  let you win  I come to what I can't give up  I need sights on targets it was the  first visit by tech ship ransom nobody  can tell there's gotta be something  other than kidnapping people maybe in  America we're in America  captain Phillips can you hear me captain  Phillips can you hear me